[Musique]
meriem est avec nous alors merci nature
aura bien alors c'est votre première
aujourd'hui on va arriver qui vous êtes
où on a fait votre connaissance dans ces
monceaux vous avez fait une sortie qui
est resté culte d'ailleurs un même match
a eu des t-shirts et a eu des sonneries
de téléphone on va regarder des extraits
ces partis kelly on voit mal extraits
non c'est pas tout monsieur que je ne
peux pas c'est je suis pas venu fait
pour s'offrir au caire s'est confondue
je ne le fais pas mais quoi mais la
famille des cafards des cafards oui mais
c'est une vraie phobie quoi c'est pas
juste une peur c'est pété un câble quoi
famille même pas aux gee les cafards
alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on attendait c'est vrai dans mega oggi
les cafards donc non mais vraiment pour
vous aviez les cafards à la maison non
non j'avais padilla femmes et enfin
quand tu grandis un petit peu au bled tu
le bled le maroc
oui tu te rencontre souvent des cafards
d'accord dit ça pour moi non ça me ça me
dit moi non mais non mais c'est vrai
donc c'est une vraie phobie donc du coup
j'ai été j'étais parler de ça et encore
ils vous ont amené des cafards sur le
plateau c'est pour ça que j'ai dit ça ah
oui bien sûr qu'il connaît vachement
leicester et d'amorcer chiite et non
merci je l'avais vous quand même merci
je suis têtu n'ai rien reçu c'est une
non non pas du tout c'est de quelle
origine
mon père est russe et ma mère est
marocaine à l'accord away non contre
moscou et 11 ans ce débat coup double
avec des jeux qui mettent votre cas
makrouds fait partie
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose à dire non oui ah non non
il ya eu tout le monde s'en tenait gens
quand j'en ai envie mais je suis content
de voir ce qui arrive en premier en
deuxième et en troisième dont on parle à
sa sortie un peu vrai y a pas de
sonnette chez moi non
[Applaudissements]
cet espace on peut qu'on peut gagner 6-1
waouh c'est bien m laurent blanc vous
avez quel âge meriem 24 ans 24 ans que
ça vous parle est ce que c'est un
animateur oui bien sûr et bien sûr ça ne
pas laisser oui tout le monde le connaît
bien sûr et c'est comme napoléon mais on
va rester sur des vannes merdique comme
ça ma version alors aller
[Musique]
et c'est pas et d'une tomate crue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est les gens qui regardent aller
donner votre avis allez on va pas faire